move on to number five which is
mercifully a bit simpler
consider the two scatter plots below so
I've got data a data B which statement
best describes the two sets and does
statement about a it's a statement about
B so the way that I do this as a sort of
exam technique if you like is to look at
the things that I know are true and then
kind of reduce down the options from
there so it's fairly straightforward to
see if you draw a trendline let's choose
a different color here a rough trend
line through set a there it has all of
the data points are sticking very close
to this rough line of best fit and in
addition to that the line of best fit
has a negative gradient so what that
tells us is number one because they all
stick close to the line of best fit
there's a strong correlation there and
if you have a look at all of the
different answers there that's no
surprise they all say strong correlation
the question is is it positive or
negative well because the gradient of
the line is going downwards it's a
negative gradient so therefore it's a
strong negative correlation so when I
look at the answers only parts B and D
say that a has a strong negative
correlation so I know it's gonna be one
of those then when I have a look at B
data set B doesn't really have much of a
correlation at all there's not really
any way you can draw a line of best fit
through that I mean all of these lines
kind of they're they're all terrible
none of them closely match the data at
all so what that is to say in this case
is there's not even something that's
vaguely close to some of those lines
everything is just completely scattered
so this is what we call not correlated
at all so if I have a look at the
answers that's going to clearly be part
or answerde so that's going to be my
answer for this question okay moving on
to six which of the following can be
classified as categorical ordinal data
so you need to know what these two
important phrases are or these two
important words categorical and ordinal
so categorical you might need to
remember it's something that has to do
with it's it's not numerical like one
two three four five so it's non
numerical or you know you might hear
this called
words like this is this is not something
which I just have straight numbers there
are categories here and then when I say
ordinal what that means is as the name
suggests you can put those different
categories in some sensible order so for
example it's not an example here but at
your grades for your exams and for your
report ABCD they're not numbers but
there is clearly an order to those
results so that would be ordinal data as
opposed to say something like what's
your favorite kind of music you know R&B
hip-hop rock and roll it's like well if
I were to put them in the list 1 2 3
which one would I put them in everyone
would disagree about what order we would
place them in so that would not be
ordinal data when you have a look ABCD
which of these fits being non numerical
and also something you can place in an
order time spent playing games each day
that would be you know an hour two hours
three hours B and D are kind of a
giveaway because they say the number of
people at a football match and then C
says your position in a queue now I
think this is the best answer Part C
because when we think about how would
you describe those you'd say they'd be
1st 2nd 3rd those would be your
positions these aren't exactly numbers I
mean I'm using words to describe them
but the numbers are um these are
cardinal things that describe order and
because there is an order 1st 2nd 3rd
otherwise it's not much of a queue
that's why I can say it's ordinal data
right now the last statistical question
in the multiple choice is number 7 the
chart below shows the favorite summer
sports of students this is a Pareto
chart so you can see it's in order of
from swimming cricket all the favourite
summer sports it's in decreasing order
so the most popular is swimming and then
cricket and so on and then you can see
that's shown by the bars but the line
graph this part here this shows the
cumulative frequency as a percentage of
well if you include all of the previous
sports then what do you get up to and
you can see by the end once you get to
hockey that's you've accumulated all of
the other sports behind it so the
cumulative percentage there it gets up
to 100
so that's the way we read this how do we
use it to interpret this question it
says what percentage of people said
cricket was their favorite sport so
there's a long way in a short way to do
this and this is a trap for people who
aren't entirely sure how to read the
Pareto chart and interpret it you can
still get the right answer
doing it the long way but it's just
going to cost you for the time it takes
to work out that calculation and then
later on you'll find you run out of time
for other questions that you could
actually have done if you had the right
amount of time so what is the long way
well a percentage of people is usually
that amount divided by the total this is
the percentage of people who said
cricket was their favourite sport now
the graph tells us if we zoom in a bit
closer cricket is this second bar here
and that's where it goes up to and you
can see if you read off to the left from
140 to 160 there's let's see here 1 2 3
4 5 marks so that makes them each four
so it goes 140 140 440 852 and so on so
this is the 144 mark so you could say oh
there's 144 people out of the total
number of people who have given the
results for their favorite sport but
that's a very long process to go through
because they don't give you a total you
have to calculate it you have to read
off this bar which is 180
you've got to read off this bar which is
132 by the looks of it you've got rid of
every single one add them all up and
then divide 144 by that total you can't
do it you'll get the right answer but
there is a much faster way if you
remember how a Pareto chart works so
remembering that this line part of a
graph this black line that goes all the
way through is a cumulative percentage
so what that tells you for example if
you have a look at this first data point
here for swimming what that means is 60
or not 60 that's the number of students
I should go over to the other side let's
have a look here to the percentages so
I'm going over to there 30% of the
students said swimming was their
favourite sport
30% is a hundred and eighty of those
students and then I can say well once I
have a look at the next part of the
cumulative percentage that goes over
from here I'm gonna go straight across
there we go so what part of the
percentage axis does this meet up to
well 50 and 60 there's arm again 4 marks
in between so it's going to go up in
twos here 52 54 56 58 up to 60 so that
makes this one 54% and I compare that to
30% so if I include swimming and cricket
because cumulative remember and that
means there are 54 percent of the people
who have swimming or cricket as their
favourite I'm not interested in swimming
or cricket I'm interested in cricket
only so I'm going to remove all that
assuming people out of there which is
the 30% that we calculated just now so
therefore I would say for just cricket
it's going to take these two
calculations or if these two numbers
rather 54% take away 30% and that's
going to give me just the cricket
figures which as you can see if you have
a look down in the possible answers
there that's Part B for 24% much quicker
than actually going through calculating
every other total and also a less
error-prone because it's quite hard you
can see I even made a brief mistake
trying to read and interpret the graph
you have to be super careful so that's
the easiest way and the fastest way to
get there